What social media accounts do you create, like Facebook business page, Instagram page,
Yelp, to increase your chance of getting a GMB as part of creating a new city niche account?
In other words, what are things you do to help improve Google acceptance?
Guys, I don't spend a bunch of time with GMB anymore, okay, because to me,
can you? Yes. Is it still possible? Yes. We actually recently got a GMB in the last two weeks,
trying some new strategies, but I have not found anything that's tried and true that I'm
confident saying, hey, here's the new strategy. What I've kind of opted to do instead is that
I am going to focus on getting better at ads and getting better at organic rankings faster,
okay, because guys, think about it like this. I've said this before, but you got to realize that
when we have with Google, right, you can get leads from paid ads, you can get leads from
the Google My Business or the local, and you can get leads from organic, and if you can get two of
those three, you're going to be just fine. Back in 2020, when I was just trying to figure things out
on more than half of my websites, or at least half of my websites, I didn't even have a GMB
because it didn't click to me. It didn't occur to me that I could use the business owner's address.
I didn't understand all this stuff, and so I was going along getting deals scaling up to $100,000
a month, not realizing that I even needed a GMB. You don't need a GMB. Now, if you can get one,
does it help? Sure, but even if I have them, I don't like to rely on them for leads because I
feel like they're always problems. You're falling off, you're doing this, you're getting suspended,
you're checking, checking, checking. So for me, I just decided, you know what, I'm going to focus
on getting better at the things that I know how to do, which is ads and organic, and if we can get
the GMB, great, if we can't, then whatever. However, I will tell you that yes, the Facebook
business page does help, the Yelp page does help, but me personally, I'm just focusing on,
I told you guys, I'm in simplification mode. I'm in, hey, these are the things I know that work,
so I'm going to focus on them, and so that's what I've tried to put my effort on. That doesn't
mean you can't, doesn't mean that's not a possibility, but that's where I'm putting my focus.